speaking of british people did you watch
the uh megan and harry interview
oh i did i didn't watch it i have no
idea what the [ __ ] it is so
i watched pieces of it uh
you know i think the the sentiment is
clear
you know the problem is like you know i
i
deleted this tweet but the
you know part people in the royal family
still think they own like india and [ __ ]
yeah like dude i saw this hilarious
thread
of people not realizing that the british
monarch doesn't
actually rule anything anymore
it's like some girl's snapchat who was
like they do yeah some girl snapchat's
like wait
so like well it's a lot like
they don't like like they couldn't
believe that like
they have nothing to do with paris or
any of the other
things that they colonized like 70 years
ago
so i'm like dying because like
you know there's you know there's just
all sorts of dark [ __ ] going on in there
yeah
so you know it's a uh
yeah i don't know man it's just like
that shitty same energy as
like as the girls that discovered vodka
soda
on tick tock yeah just be like wait it's
like wait
wait the queen doesn't actually they
don't like doesn't really do anything
well then why the [ __ ] why is it a lot
of written
royal family it's like no one answer
that dude
real estate that's why everybody [ __ ]
knows they just why do people care i
don't know
you you for the last 20 years you
[ __ ] been kneeling to the
property brothers
that's all you've been doing and playing
dress-up with the property brothers
[Laughter]
i grant the knight of property brothers
l.a
[Laughter]
i will serve you i will sell sunset
i will protect and sell sunset
[Laughter]
for you queen
but so what what are the clips like
people are kind of put off by it or
something like that or what no i mean
like she just like you know
she got a lot of the you know the
in their experience just like a lot of
code switching and
you know uh like what seems
would feel like i actually only know the
british tabloid headlines which
seem just like very blatant shitty
contradictions
and you know like the one example was
like avocado toast
like for uh the other dude's wife i
don't know her [ __ ] name
you know it was like she eats avocado
toast and the british
you know tabloids would refer to that as
like a healthy way to nurture her baby
and then they would like write the same
[ __ ] about meghan markle but it's like
her avocado diet is linked to child
labor
you know it's like just like comically
horrible attacks like you're just like
what
so that's the extent of what i know and
what was the point of the interview
what was the point i don't know anything
about the royal family like at all i
think the point of the interview is just
to kind of like tell their side because
the
you know like the british the
media is just kind of tore em up
and everyone thinks they're bozos and
disgraces
and that she's making stuff up and i
don't know man
it's it's like weird how invested people
are in the royal family
and how no one could believe that
a [ __ ] an institution that is
old as [ __ ] and it's been around for
like
you know way long you know people can't
believe that they might have treated her
shitty
based on the way that she looks you know
couldn't be that
so i think it was like megan and harry
just sort of addressing that
like nah they feel like that's what went
on and uh
now it's it's like they're kind of cut
off from the family they don't have like
security
coverage anymore and i think
that
i think that like scares harry because
of like what happened to
his mom obviously diana so
someone in the royal family was
concerned what color the baby would be
oh yeah yeah there was like yeah oh [ __ ]
i forgot about that there's like
yeah if that's not obvious enough they
would like
have discussions about the other babies
like skin color
so as yeah like what do you mean saying
it's gonna be a different race because
that and like they would um be like
they're concerned with how like dark the
child would be
that was my understanding which is
[ __ ] the royal family was
yeah oh yeah yeah he wouldn't be given a
title
and like they didn't give her like i
believe they didn't give her like a
strong reason as to why
it's just like oh yeah he's not going to
be named prince
weird so they're racist
also is she not having a baby with harry
like wouldn't it just be white because
they're both white or are they not both
white
no no bro megan is come on
she's not white no look at her let's see
i don't know what she looks like
i like you [ __ ]
okay okay
so she's not white then
what is she i should have not said
anything you should have just looked at
her face and like
oh i see
megan mark marco's race is the basis for
all the outrage they said
megan's kid oh okay so it but
it's is her race known
um i think so
but i mean you know it's kind of
irrelevant right like
the fact that they're even saying [ __ ]
i'm just trying to understand
why this conversation is happening
that's all yeah yeah no it's just that
so she's not white and they're concerned
with how the baby is gonna look when it
comes out
i mean it's like it's like a multitude
of things but the underscore
or like the sort of overall
theme here is racism yeah and
um yeah so
why do people i mean give a [ __ ] about
the royal family
that's the part that's the part that
cares that is the part that like i
cannot understand
like you know that's some very because
even
i mean like english people we know
they don't give a [ __ ] so it's got to be
a generational thing right like
they used to be important um
yeah i don't know you think i mean how
[ __ ] with them
yeah we should ask gen z
y'all rocking with the royal family
y'all rocking with the royal family
i don't think so man
we got to tell them how they you know
they murdered
they murdered one of their own in a in a
tunnel
in a [ __ ] limousine yeah
i mean that i mean that's r.i.p yeah
r.i.p that's the
is that a conspiracy or what what is the
d i don't know
with princess diana yeah i mean bro
there's
right there's a lot of she got killed
she didn't die on accident
yeah i mean there's a lot of theories
around that that she
it was a planned thing
why um i don't actually know
i just know that there are theories that
it it was a it was not an accident
driver was drunk paparazzi stormed the
car
at a tunnel driver was speeding like
crazy yeah that was the story yeah but
i'm saying
yeah but why what if if she did get
killed why did she get killed why did
they
like have her murdered uh
i don't know i think that she i think
that when she came into the royal family
i think they
i think they didn't like her
i think that was for sure
um oh and then oh and then harry harry
was like
the product of another man i believe she
had slept with another man or something
um yeah so you know it's just uh
again it's like [ __ ] these people
who gives a [ __ ] you know yeah
if anything if anything they're you know
i think they just uh they they love the
attention i think that's what it is
yeah like whenever i've gone to london
and we've seen those buildings and
you know they got the furry hat guys out
there and like they won't let you in
it's just bizarre to me like why is
there just this
i mean i guess you know i kind of
answered this question already but
it's been there forever right like maybe
that building's been there a long time
so that's why people give a [ __ ] but if
they don't rule over anything
then why the [ __ ] do they get like this
you know this like
public display case in front of
everybody
people yeah and every time you walk
through that [ __ ] there's so many
people just standing outside that [ __ ]
waiting for someone to come out weird as
[ __ ]
yeah yeah so i would love to know why
people care
if you care let us know why you care let
us know we'd love to let us know how you
care about the royal family
today
you